my name's dara
i'm i've invented a programming language
called neta
um but what i'd like to
talk to you today is to try and convince
you
of the importance of symmetry in
programming language design
so i'm not just describing nerta i'm
using
nota as an example of
this approach to designing languages and
how it helps
and and i'm going to be talking about
that in general
and then going through the sub-languages
of nerda
in order of decreasing symmetry and
maybe if we have time
and some discussion of how to implement
things efficiently
can everyone hear me by the way
okay is that better now thank you
um okay so
what do i see the problem as being in uh
facing programming language designers
well
computers have become huge in terms of
their power
and their storage capacity
we need languages that
can express powerful abstractions in
order to reduce complexity
and this quote by dykstra which is too
long to read
um is wonderful
[Music]
so he's saying that in 1972 because the
size of computers
had increased by a thousand-fold but
they were too complicated
well since then they've been they've
increased by another million-fold
and in terms of storage for a given
price
and that's improved by i think seven
orders of magnitude
so have languages and tools improved
enough over that time
and i don't think so i think we're still
in a software crisis
because um our programs are too large
and complex
and we don't know how to write correct
secure and reliable programs um
importantly we don't know how to write
them at economical effort
so um to get back to the political point
about the nsa
the nsa has been successful in
exploiting
flaws in widely used software
because the tools and languages that we
have
are not good enough to be able to write
secure software
in practice i mean
you can if you spend enough effort if
you
do the kind of things that say nasa is
doing uh
software that uses on the space station
then you can write secure
and uh reliable software um
no one does that in practice apart from
nasa
a few others um so
i i claim that correctness security and
reliability are three sides of the same
coins metaphorical
kinds that can have three sides um
and we have techniques that help with
this
um like pure functional programming and
object-oriented programming
but we need to understand how they help
um and i think the way that they help
is by imposing symmetries um
so a symmetry uh in general the
um kind of symmetry that you might have
learnt um
in junior high school or whatever are
geometrical symmetries
um so if you change a shape in a
particular way
then you get a similar shape similarly
you can
change a program in a particular way and
get a similar program
so in the simplest case a program that
does the same thing
and this concept also applies in physics
um
so uh there's charge priority uh
time symmetry um you
change everything to antimatter um swap
things
mirror things in space and change the
direction of time and everything works
out the same
okay in programming you have lots of
very interesting symmetries that apply
or that nearly apply to practical
programming languages
um some of these
don't actually apply to full programming
languages that
people use in practice because they have
these
particular warts and special cases
um and what i'm trying to claim is that
we could
we should pay attention to those what's
in special cases and try to
reduce or eliminate them
um so some examples you've got
confluence
which is that in a pure functional
language
you can evaluate things in different
orders and you'll get the same result
and you can move pure functions to
different parts of a program
and they'll still give the same result
so
and you can have symmetries that are
associated with particular
operators and functions you can rename
variables
and you can add and remove annotations
that this is an interesting category of
uh symmetries
um for example functional abstraction so
um you can take inline code
extract it to a function and call that
function
and that will give you an equivalent
program and similarly with
macros modules and types in zooms
okay obvious one at the end which is
almost too obvious to see
is comments and you can make arbitrary
changes to the comments in the program
and it won't do any
anything to what the program does
that by the way is not true in c
um because of the the texture of actual
system
um okay so many languages and properties
uh interfere with symmetries that we
would like to have in our language
and some of those interfering features
are really quite important um things
like side effects
state failure handling and concurrency
and some of these other ones well we can
leave those out from a language
perfectly fine no one uses dynamic
binding anymore
um implicit coercions if you've ever
used the language
with implicit coercions like javascript
i mean i know
javascript is the favorite language to
bash
um the implicit coercions
um cause a fair proportion of the bugs
that you
uh you end up introducing
um and features
that are unhygienic in the sense that
they
break obstruction so for example if you
have a function
in some languages that will be opaque
but in other languages
you'll be able to extract its codes
change its code to
reflection on it and that breaks
symmetry
and of course everything anything that
violates memory safety
um okay and you can end up misdesigning
a feature
so that it doesn't have the symmetries
that you would naively assume that it
would do
um so
one of the things we can do is just
leave out these features and that gives
us a simple
simpler language so um if we possibly
can leave out these features then we
should
but what about the ones and that we
really need
like side effects failure handling and
concurrency
um i i'm going to claim that we do need
concurrency um
i know some languages do without it but
it's becoming more
more important um
so what we can do about this is to
define stratified languages
so languages with different levels of
complexities
and in a language that's say a pure
functional
and all functions terminate
um and at the outer level you have
mutual stake currency
value handling everything that you would
expect
in a full language and my claim is that
usually for practical programs
you can um write most of your code
in the inner languages and use the auto
answer coordination language
and the claim is that this will give you
a program that
is overall easier to reason about and
obviously this isn't
not a new idea because that's the idea
behind haskell
it's um to make sense the idea behind a
lang
which has um a functional language to
define processes
and then a concurrent coordination
language
so that's the idea that we're using but
we're going to take it further
and at each level of the language
we're going to add features and we're
going to break one of the symmetries
that we had
at the previous level um
some of these symmetries they're so
useful that we shouldn't break them at
all
for example the um actor locality laws
are a set of laws that um
define or constrain how information
propagates through a program or
how authority propagates through a
program um
this was work done by carl hewitt and
goliga in the 70s i think um
and they're really very important for be
being able to constrain um
what programs in language can do so we
want to
retain those in full language
and there's a trade-off between keeping
the number of levels small to keep it
understandable
and sort of optimizing the curve which
gives you a given expressiveness for a
given symmetry
um but we can always collapse the levels
later
um i'm
going to be short on time so i'll skip
some of this i
really encourage people to uh read
through the slides in detail because
they're
they're very dense um as you may have
noticed
um
and they'll be on the web obviously um
so i've lost my track
uh yeah the there's another
issue which happens when you have a
stratified language
is are you retaining the properties
of the inner languages when you
compose them in the coordination
language
it's important that you do because
otherwise you lose the advantages of
stratification so an analogy of this
if you have if you consider
the inner languages to be an
ordered state of matter like a solid the
outer languages to be a gas or whatever
then if you move a solid within a gas
it retains its shape its rigidity
and similarly what you want to happen is
that when you move um
sub programs and that are highly ordered
within the coordination language that
they also retain their properties
and it's easy to end up breaking that
actually
um yeah i'm going to skip this slide
okay so um the neuter language
um it's an object capability language um
i don't know how many of you are
familiar with that but
um it's an approach to security which
basically says that um
if you have a reference to something
then you have
the authority to operate on that thing
so um it avoids having a separate layer
of access control
because um the
um the flow of authority
within the program reflect its
functionality that you don't need to add
extra access control on
afterward it's parallel it's concurrent
um i've separated those two because
um concurrency
is really complicated it's really
complicated to reason about
but parallelism
for efficiency can be done
in a pure functional um
so if we separate those two then we're
optimizing the symmetry expressiveness
okay and i'm only going to talk about
semantics um i don't really care that
much about syntax
and we can use the syntax of any
language we like
okay those are the reasons why i think a
new language is needed
okay why is it called neta well emmy
nurture was a um
a physicist uh in the uh did most of her
work in 1920s and 1930s
um and she
was well known for her study of symmetry
and physics
and in mathematics
and actually there are some technical
reasons why
[Music]
her work applies directly to nerta
because we can
consider the inner languages as a
neterian
rewriting system
and we can always also use analogies
with physics like we have done
so i'm going into a lot of detail on
this slide and there's uh quite a bit of
mathematics on it
um i i encourage people to
look at the mathematics later um
but it's it's not practical for me to
explain all of it here
basically what we're doing is um
modeling
the execution of the language as a
rewriting system
so we rewrite terms to
simpler terms in order to model
evaluation
and we need to go into this much
detail and take this much care about it
in order to make sure that we
get the symmetry properties that we want
very easy thing to make mistakes with
i'll just point out a bit of the
notation that i'm going to be using
later that this three-line swiggle
equivalence operator is one of the most
important things
because what that says is that two terms
two programs are equivalent
and they're they're equivalent in any
context that you might use them
so nerta is a non-deterministic language
in general
and the way it handles failure is that
any
program is allowed to fail
if it's deterministic then it gives a
single answer or it fails
and i think that's necessary because we
need to be able to model
um cases where um real
computers fail to
[Music]
to satisfy the ideal model of a computer
for example they've run out of memory
or um the network breaks or um
there's a hardware failure failure or
whatever and if we include that within
our model of the language and then we're
being worried
more realistic
okay so symmetry parties that always
hold
basically are for renaming
properties that um might hold in
particular subsets
so um a lot of this is basic computer
science really
but we need to be careful about um the
case of failures
and because a lot of the the work that's
been done in fundamental computer
science
doesn't really consider failures very
wide um it considers
um terminating languages that
always give you a given result which
isn't actually very realistic
okay so these are properties um
that might hold for a pure language and
this one is interesting on foldability
and basically it says that if you have a
function definition
um and this this
v x means some expression that uses x
um and you have s and t which are
equivalent expressions and you
substitute
s you call f with expression
s then you get the same thing
as expanding the function body with the
equivalent thing
t so that's called unfoldability and
it's basically the essence of pure
functional programming
sometimes people say that referential
transparency is the essence of
functional programming
but these two things do not actually
imply each other in a
non-deterministic language
right so this is the the structure of
the overall language
so we have the um the most structured
uh subset on the top left there um
uh which is uh nuta p and
that already includes parallelism
because it turns out that
parallelism doesn't break any symmetry
properties
a parallel program can do exactly the
same
as a serial program and be just as easy
to reason about because the parallelism
is in some sense
automatic
and then we add features in turn so
we add failure handling um
and as we add failure handling for
example that breaks the
the execution order independence
um because of obviously when a failure
happens affair
affects which value you get
these two languages the red and orange
ones
are not even sure and complete because
you can
you can do a lot in languages that
aren't true and complete
so most programs on most subprograms are
intended to terminate
and even when you
have a large program say say for example
a web server um each request
to the web server is intended to
terminate um
and almost all of your code is in the
handling of those requests
the bit that sort of loops over requests
is in a framework probably um
and then we we add some less interesting
features
um oh then we add
mutual state so when we add mutual state
we know we no longer have a functional
language
and so we lose all these symmetries that
are associated with functional languages
um after that we
add currency we first of all add
concurrency
um in a form that's very easy to reason
about because it's
um basically static data flow so um one
of the talks before
was saying that we want
fixed data flow networks in order to
to be able to reason about them yes
that's true
but it doesn't mean that the whole
language has to be restricted to fix
data flow
[Music]
and then on the outside
we have an event loop language so
i don't know how many of you uh know
about event loop concurrency but it's
it's basically the language that's used
or going to be used in
the model that's going to be used in
javascript in lots of web applications
it's used in languages like e and um
sort of erlang so it's a very expressive
model
but it's not um the same as
shared state concurrency with threads
and locks
um because those turn out to be
impossible to reason about
um i mean i know someone some people
have tried with
type systems that try to ensure locking
i don't think it works very well
okay um
influences on nurture all those things
but we haven't got time to go through
them
okay um a lot of the languages
that are um
sort of have a reputation for being safe
languages things like
um haskell or camel they have loopholes
so um here are two examples
um in our camel there's this um module
that's part of the standard library
um which is to do um marshalling and
martian and also called serialization um
and it's unsafe and you can very easily
crush the the whole program by using it
um similarly in haskell
um you have unsafe things like um
on say from perform web it's really good
that they have unsafe in their names i
mean it's not trying to mislead anything
anyone and you have to import them from
the unsafe module
um so that's fine but they still um
do crash your program if you use them um
a subtle point here is that these
primitives
are used all over the haskell libraries
um so even if
you were um have a pure functional
program
and if you use things
like statements or whatever they're
going to be using this under the hood
and you have to rely on the fact that
the library writers
have used them correctly and if you look
on the haskell
wiki that there's a bunch of conditions
for how to safely use unsafe perform io
and the very compiler dependence and
implementation dependent
so the basic problem here is that we
have
a lack of expressiveness in how to do
these things safely um so example that
the actual thing this program is trying
to do
needn't be unsafe and that similarly for
the o'camel uh example
there are ways to do typesafe
serialization and serialization
but this particular ocam library didn't
use them
okay so by designing a language in terms
of symmetries
they keep us honest in language design
so for example suppose we want to avoid
implicit coercions
there are some behaviors that we might
include in our language
that are like implicit coercions but
because they're not
like what we recognize as an implicit
version from other languages
we don't know that that's what we've
effectively added
but that kind of thing will end up
breaking symmetries
and we'll have to either explicitly
include that feature in another level of
language
or we'll have to avoid it entirely
so as i say it keeps us honest in the
language design
okay um so even in
safe languages um
it's there are certain kinds of language
properties that
um make it much more difficult to avoid
bugs
so for example um if you have a language
with
moderate modular arithmetic or floating
point arithmetic
in place of integers
you're going to have a mental model in
your head
of what addition means that
is basically mathematical addition
and if you implement that using an
operator that
actually does modulo addition or
floating point addition
then you're going to make mistakes and
this is an example of an actual mistake
that's made in
um secure secure ecmascript
and basically that there was a corner
case at the top
range of the um
the set of integers that can be
expressed as
floating point exactly and the problem
here is divergence from intuition
oh i'll i'll just say how nerta
addresses that so
don't have operations that do the wrong
thing
and this is actually quite hard but
remember that
operations are allowed to fail so
instead of doing uh modular arithmetic
for example
we can have an offer an addition that
fails if you get the wrong
answer um
sporting programming without state
because state is one of the things that
um
if if you get into an inconsistent state
then it's very
um difficult to recover if you didn't
use state in the first place then you
have no inconsistency
um and transactionality
so um transactions are probably familiar
from
database programming um and to some
extent that they've started
to be adopted into language design
and things like software transactional
memory
[Music]
but they haven't made
much of an inroad into commonly used
languages they're still sort of a
research project
and the um a big reason
for that is performance
so most software
transactional memory systems for example
have um
if you try to run them on two processors
then they're i don't know 10 20
times slower than running on one
processor
so but we can do transaction
transactional
programming efficiently and if i have
time um i'll explain how it's done
so i mean a lot of the compromises made
in
language design are because of
performance or perceived performance
so um if you remember the slide
um from near the beginning where the
performance of computers had increased
by a million-fold in 30 years
you might think that no one should
really care about performance anymore
but as dijkstra said
we're trying to solve more difficult
problems
in your smartphone for example you
you've
got all of this graphics and
bells and whistles that it's trying to
do at the same
time as computing something and the
actual computing something
um may be quite trivial
um but because of all these uh bells and
whistles
it it's still not necessarily fast as
you
perceive it to run
yeah another quote that i love about
security
so hor gets it spot on here
um he says that every syntactically
correct program should give a result or
error message
predictable and comprehensible in terms
of the source language
so if you need to understand the
implementation
in order to understand the errors that
your program is giving you then you
don't have very much chance of
fixing the book and it's possible to
design that
problem out of languages and but there
are still
far too many languages in common use
where that's not done i mean c is very
very commonly used still but it's not
just c it's
lots of failure cases and even
languages that are perceived to be more
safe
okay so let's um go into
um detail about the actual languages
that are part of nerta
so we start off with um a deterministic
strict pure functional language um where
everything terminates remember that um
failure is always an option
so we either succeed and give a single
answer
or we fail in a finite time um
failing in a finite time doesn't mean
that um
it's going to fail in a practical length
of time
but my claim here is that if we
write in languages that are terminating
then we'll understand better what the
um
even though we're not guaranteed to
terminate
in a practical length of time we're less
likely to make bugs
that cause us to have infinite loops
because
we can't do that in the language
so we will understand the performance
better even though the language isn't
controlling performance per se
and actually we can analyze security
features
that allow us to control performance as
well
but that's a separate problem
okay um as
more justification of allowing programs
to fail
so um symmetry is
associated with equational reasoning so
um
okay the program is deterministic its
outcome and side effects are dependent
only on its input state determinism is a
weaker property than
being pure functional um you can have a
deterministic
program that still uses mutual states
that
still does have side effects but they're
always the same side effects every time
you run it
so neta 0 is deterministic but so much
uh uh uh quite a few of the
uh larger languages are also
deterministic um
[Music]
okay we we've gone through time uh
location variants before so you move up
a pure program to a different place
then it computes the same result um
and that also applies if you
move it to a different task in a in the
concurrent
languages languages if you remember
before we were talking about coherence
the properties that
um sort of structured success retain
their properties
and that's an example of that
uh how are we doing for time by the way
five minutes more yeah okay right
um so
okay so because we don't have a mutable
state and because all programs terminate
we can we can treat definitions within
the programmers equations so for example
here we have a program
that doesn't terminate
and so would be excluded from this
subset
and because it doesn't terminate
and this attempt to use equation
reasoning fails because we subtract
loop x from both sides we get zero
equals what and that
fails because the program didn't
terminate
so that the properties that neta zero
actually has
is definiteness so that's
the fact that a program gives
a specific result or it fails
you might say if we're not enforcing
success
then what's the advantage of that well
the advantage is that
we still have this on photo foldability
reasoning property
that holds even if in the case of
failure um
so that's actually the same
unfoldability property that we discussed
before i haven't updated the slide to
say that
and if a program fails we can recover
from that
if it goes into an infill
infinite loop then detecting that is
possible
but the problem is that you have to use
something like a timeout
and a timeout makes your program
non-deterministic
so you lose the symmetry prophecy either
way
so how do we approve termination well we
do it automatically
um termination proving is a a well
understood um problem um
i think a lot of a lot of people have
the impression
um that non-showing complete languages
are useless
um actually
um you can say so much without showing
completeness
that it's likely to be only a tiny
uh part of your program that can't be
automatically
proven terminating
i i've already gone through this about
bugs that cause excessive from time
so the next thing we add to this um
strict sequential pure function language
is parallelism
this is an approach that um
has been researching that originally in
the silk language
um it's now an intel project called silk
plus
um called fork joint parallelism
and the the property of this is it
allows you to run things in parallel
but it has exactly the same semantics as
a serial program and actually the
original silk
that statement wasn't quite true because
a program could have race conditions
and in the case where it has race
conditions then it doesn't behave the
same way as
a sequential language but because we're
enforcing these extra symmetry
properties
we can guarantee that there are no race
conditions
and like i say that not only does this
give parallelism it's actually quite
efficient in practice
and there's been lots of research on how
to do this
well using um work stealing schedulers
and they produce well not
optimal results but um so within a
constant factor of
optimal scheduling
okay and yeah
like i say improvement so we have
identical parallel and serial
thematics and the restrictions we make
um relative to silk aren't going to be
a problem because we'll add full
concurrency later
okay
yeah we're running out of time
okay this is a justification for why we
want explicit parallelism
annotations rather than having
everything being uh being fit
uh the next thing we add is um local
mutual state
so that's mutual state that only applies
within a function
um and because it only applies within a
function
um we can um so we could compile it out
we could
um produce an equivalent pure functional
program
so although it makes that particular
function
more difficult to understand it's not
making the whole program more difficult
to understand
although it does break some symmetries
there's this interesting symmetry called
um landing correspondence which is
basically
um sort of um
inlining functions um
and this doesn't quite hold because of
the mutual state
so we we have lost something the next
thing we add
is failure handling
so failure handling in nata is
transactional
if like in a database transaction if
you get an integrity um violation then
the
the transaction you're in will be rolled
back
now inerta that applies to every
function call
i explain later why that isn't as
expensive as it sounds
um
so this is not like exception handling
with reception handling if um
gets an exception then the state may
have been updated
by the point you get the exception you
know
because the you lose information about
exactly when the
exception happened um
it's actually very difficult to um
recover from that inconsistent state
and inertia it happens automatically so
um c plus plus programmers
um call this the strong exception
guarantee and inertia you have it
automatically for every function
um okay
and we lose another symmetry about
evaluation
there um yeah we're not going to have
time for this
okay okay um so you
then add true and completeness text and
then you add
um laziness um
and then static names which are um
they're like um nonces in uh oz if you
know what that is
um and then you
add reducers which are a way of
um they're a weaker form of state so
um they're more easier to reason about
than um
than full useful state
okay and then
and we had full state um we
only had task local states so um as in
languages like a lang which we message
passing concurrency
we have no state that is shared between
different tasks and can be accessed
directly
transactions okay
i'm not going to have um time obviously
to um
to justify why transactions are not too
expensive
um so you have to read the slides
afterwards
there's a detailed justification of that
the next thing we had is um data flow
concurrency but we had
deterministic concurrency so um
uh basically the the restriction here
is that because you're only waiting for
one possible event
um everything is deterministic
okay and then
eventually we had the whole thing
message passing concurrency and event
loops
um now the language that we have at the
end here
is still um quite easy to reason about
it
it's similar to languages like e and
jewel and olang
so it's still completely memory safe
[Music]
it doesn't have race conditions or it
doesn't have low level race conditions
um it's pretty easy well
it's never easy to write secure programs
but you're more likely to be able to
write it than in
some other languages
okay um
oh and there's a there's a distributed
extension
um which has the same semantics as the
um
the language on the single machine
and it's um this uses a a protocol
called
can and which is almost magical in its
ability to recover from failure
but you can read about that later okay
and
lots of security features confirming
whatever okay questions
let's take questions at lunch